منذ أن تحدثنا مؤخرًا ، من الواضح أنه
كان هناك الكثير من التقارير حول المزيد من
الموضوعات
الشخصية وقد تؤثر على المؤسسة ، لذلك
أريد فقط أن أطرح عليك بضعة أسئلة
حول ذلك وأعلم أنك تشعر بأن بعض
الأشياء قد تم الإبلاغ عنها بشكل خاطئ ، لذا
سأبدأ للتو.
من الواضح أنك في مايو
أعلنت أنت وزوجتك ميليندا أنكما تنتهيان
زواجكما بعد 27 عامًا يوم الاثنين
من هذا الأسبوع ، تم الانتهاء من الطلاق
على المستوى الشخصي فقط كيف حالك
أه إنه بالتأكيد معلم محزن للغاية
آه
في ميليندا شخص عظيم و  أه
تلك الشراكة التي وصلنا إلى
نهايتها مصدر حزن شخصي كبير
أه نحن إه
نتواصل ونعمل في
المؤسسة ولذا فإن تلك الشراكة سنحاول
ونواصل المؤسسة وقالت إنه
سيكون هناك مثل  فترة تجريبية مدتها سنتان
لترى أنه
إذا كان بإمكانكما الاستمرار في العمل معًا ،
فهذا هو أملك في
أنه يمكنك نعم ، تتمتع ميليندا
بنقاط قوة لا تصدق
أنها تجلبها  ساعدت المؤسسة في أن تكون أفضل ،
لقد استمتعنا دائمًا بعملنا
معًا ،
فأنت تعلم أن بإمكان اثنين منا الخروج والعمل
مع القادة
والمساعدة في بناء المنظمة حتى تعرف
أن هذا سيكون
بالتأكيد أفضل شيء
للمؤسسة ،
هناك عدة أشياء  التقارير
التي كانت موجودة هناك أريد أن أسألك
عنها وأعتقد أنه ليس من شأن أحد ما
يحدث في زواج شخص ما في
نيويورك تايمز ومجلة وول ستريت
في الأشهر الأخيرة
أن ميليندا كانت قلقة بشأن
العلاقة التي
تربطك بجيفري إبستين  من الذي في الوقت الذي قابلته فيه في عام
كان قد أدين بالفعل بالتماس
الدعارة من قاصر ،
في المرات التي ذكرت فيها أنها استعانت
بمحامين طلاق في وقت قريب
من أكتوبر 2019 عندما أصبح هذا الاتصال مع
إبستين علنيًا ،
هل يمكنك شرح علاقتك
بإبستين هل كان لديك أي منها  هل
كان هناك أي مخاوف لديك
حيال ذلك ،
بالتأكيد أه أنت تعلم
أنني تناولت عدة وجبات عشاء معه أه أنت تعلم
آمل ذلك
في قال عن الحصول على مليارات من
الأعمال الخيرية للصحة العالمية من
خلال جهات الاتصال التي قد
تظهر ،
كما تعلم عندما بدا أن هذا لم
يكن شيئًا حقيقيًا ،
انتهت العلاقة ولكن كان من
الخطأ
الفادح قضاء بعض الوقت معه لمنحه
مصداقيتك تعلم أن هناك الكثير من
الآخرين أه
في نفس الموقف لكني أخطأت